tu as apporté ma veste oui j'ai eu une
longue conversation avec la vendeuse et
au final j'ai réussi ce qu'il voulait
rembourse veut la récupérer
je m'en charge cet ordi du maire de
refuser mon mot de passe ça c'était bien
elle va prendre le mur alors suivez-moi
mignot et ne m'effraie pas surtout tu
n'auras qu'à mettre une berceuse et
augmenter doucement le volume qu'est ce
que vous faites ici toujours la dernière
ici
moi je suis toujours le dernier kirsten
eric sont toujours ici alors on acclame
les enfermer dans une pièce il se jette
roland sur l'autre pendant qu'ils
poseront nous on sera libre on voudrait
arrêter l'ascenseur quelques minutes
pour que deux personnes tombent
amoureuses l'une de l'autre vont pour oc
qui lui il faut que vous sortiez
messieurs c'est exactement comme dans
mes cauchemars
qu'est ce que vous faites est là
on connaît tout sur nos boss ce qu'ils
aiment ce qu'ils détestent nous sommes
les hommes derrière le rideau est ce que
ray cadets bonne place pour les yankees
non il aurait garé depuis les gradins
comme toi et moi oui bien sûr question
il faut que ces deux personnes
s'embrassent
[Applaudissements]
je ne reviens pas aujourd'hui je peux
que j'arrive cas on a réussi les deux
points a permis à deux personnes
malheureuses de retrouver le volant et
piano
[Musique]
et vous vous connaissez bien c'est cool
tu as dit ça sur ce ton là ta voix est
devenu aigu
[Musique]
costes rouges comme quoi il serait pas
croire qu'ils peuvent apprendre comment
le monde fonctionne sur toi
où
on fait comme dans un new canon c'est
faux j'ai vu ce classique avec lindsay
lohan a cette fois pour savoir qu'on est
en plein dans un scénar comme celui là
tout ce que je veux moi c'est une plus
être une assistante une fois mes 27 ans
révolus j'ai 28 ans aux mondiaux je suis
désolé pour toi c'est trop triste pour
toi
[Musique]